[Musique]
on est très heureux de d'ouvrir
aujourd'hui la nouvelle saison de l'été
du jardin du Luxembourg et nous ouvrons
cet espace à l'expression artistique des
artistes qui des photographes des
sculpteurs des peintres des dessinateurs
viennent exposer leurs œuvres pendant
tous l'été il y aura plus de 19
expositions dans ce pavillon de
l'Orangerie cinq autres dans un pas un
autre pavillon le pavillon d'avion de du
jardin du Luxembourg et c'est un moyen
de faire du Sénat un moyen d'ouverture à
la culture à des expressions artistiques
les plus diverses
c'est un vrai plaisir de d'être exposé
dans ce lieu magique qui est l'Orangerie
du jardin du Luxembourg le fait avoir
été choisie ça m'a vraiment touché je me
suis dit j'ai dû parler à quelque chose
dont les gens ont besoin en ce moment
pour moi c'est un honneur de rester là
pendant 12 jours c'est aussi rencontrer
le monde entier en fait c'est de voir
tout une population qui change d'heure
en heure il y a beaucoup de monde il y a
des gens qui sont des gens du quartier
il y a aussi des touristes qui viennent
dans le jardin du Luxembourg et qui
voient de la lumière et entre on a des
familles voilà donc il y a Samuel
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de monde les
gens viennent vers vous
dire aux œuvres et donc c'est un point
de vue vraiment différent mais
extrêmement intéressant
[Musique]
ces expositions sont gratuites tout le
monde peut venir les visiter il y a eu
plus de 86 000 visiteurs l'an dernier
qui sont venus et donc nous nous sommes
ravis de pouvoir à travers cette
initiative à la fois nous ouvrir au
monde des artistes et puis nous tourner
vers le public en lui disant venez en
profiter venez découvrir ces images
sensibles sur sur le monde
[Musique]